we know that Americans are working until
later and later in their lives we know
that Americans are having children older
and older and usually it's all under the
assumption that everybody's living
longer and when we're going to continue
living longer and longer but recently
that has actually not been the trend
American life expectancy has been
declining and that's not exactly the
pinnacle of successful and advanced
nations right sometimes life expectancy
numbers can be misleading or at least
confusing like for example if you
decrease infant mortality and reduce the
number of people that die before they
turn 1 or 5 depending on how you measure
it you're going to increase life
expectancy but it doesn't really mean
that people who make it to adulthood
will live longer it's just a number
that's impacted by the reduction of
infant mortality but the data is
genuinely getting worse for what for
life expectancy in the United States the
u.s. age adjusted mortality rates rose
1.2 percent from 2014 to 2015 according
to the Society of Actuaries that is the
first year-over-year increase dating all
the way back to 2005 and this is a
stunning number this is only the second
rise greater than 1 percent since 1980
Americans in their late 50s are having
more serious health problems than people
in their late 50s did 10 or 15 years ago
despite advancements in treatment for
many conditions quality of life is down
the number of middle-aged Americans with
activity of daily living limitations is
up from eight point eight percent to
twelve point five percent now what does
that mean activity of daily living
limitations that is a measure of how
many people have trouble with day-to-day
activities like walking across a room
bathing and dressing by oneself eating
by oneself getting in and out of bed by
oneself and we're also seeing that it's
not just physical but cognitive skills
have been declining over time for those
with a retirement age of 66 11 percent
already had some kind of dementia or
cognitive decline by age 58 or 60
according to the study and
is also up but the policy still is
moving as if life expectancy is going up
so for example the age for claiming full
Social Security benefits is being
increased from 65 to 67 by 2027 that
might make sense if people are living
longer and longer but we're seeing
increased mortality rates retirement is
being postponed 20% of Americans in
their early 70s are still working now
that is a number that's on the rise that
would make perfect sense if people were
living longer and longer it's not what
we're seeing and I've talked about some
of the causes at least among middle-aged
white people who are having problems
with life expectancy some factors
include alcohol abuse drug overdoses
suicide higher rates of obesity but
there are many other factors lack of
exercise which I guess can correlate sir
or is related to obesity is a factor
processed foods environmental pollution
can't possibly be helping the stress
caused by huge debt sometimes for
people's entire lives based on credit
card debt that is accumulated as a
result of student loan debt which is a
major major crisis in the United States
and you know who lower life expectancy
is good for pension plans pension plant
plans of different kinds that are
defined benefit that are committed to
sending recipients money for as long as
they live if people don't live as long
that's good for the pockets of pension
plan companies and really I think we
need to be having I don't know if
conversations the right word but a sort
of intervention when it comes to the
culture of busyness as I call it and the
the culture that has developed in the
United States and it's become work work
work work work work and then drop dead
but enjoy the freedom that we have in
the United States I guess to do whatever
you want as long as you're working all
the way up until you die and I can start
picking out little things we can change
Oh reduce the workweek by a few hours or
let's try to deal with student
and college costs all are worthwhile
endeavors but this broader status quo is
inherent to the economic system we live
in now you might hear that and say oh
there you go on your socialist rantings
I'm not a socialist I'm not advocating
for socialism but we need a different
type of capitalism something more like
the Scandinavian model it's just the
reality because a lot of the problems
we're experiencing and the life
expectancy issue connects to that we
can't do piecemeal changes the system
really has to be overhauled and there's
no indication that's going to happen
anytime soon